Britta Haselmann jetzt von dem Screen
eine der beiden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
meine Damen und Herren von diesem
Gipfeltreffen muss ein Signal der
Geschlossenheit ausgehen und ich bin mir
sicher dass wir das auch
Geschlossenheit um unser gemeinsames
Vorgehen bei den sanktionspaketen bei
den finanziellen
humanitären und bei der militärischen
Unterstützung
deutlich zu machen zu unterstreichen und
klarzumachen dass sie das schärfste
Schwert sind gegen Putin europäische
Geschlossenheit die Geschlossenheit der
sieben und der internationalen
Staatengemeinschaft sind in dieser Krise
das wichtigste von was wir haben meine
Damen und Herren und gleichzeitig werden
hoffentlich und davon bin ich davon
gehen wir aus ganz klare Signale
ausgehen
europäische und nationale Maßnahmen
gegen hohe Energiepreise werden Hand in
Hand gehen dafür machen wir uns stark
der gemeinsame Einkauf von Gas die
Senkung des Verbrauchs und die
versifizierung von Energiequellen durch
erneuerbare ein Booster für erneuerbare
Energien und auch einer übergewinnsteuer
die zur Veränderung sozialer Härten in
den Nationalstaaten und europäisch in
der unterschiedlichen Lage der Staaten
dient das werden gemeinsame Botschaften
sein und Aufträge die wir uns wechselt
seitlich erteilen und das ist gut und
wichtig so dass dieses Signal aus Europa
ausgehen wird beim Europäischen Rat
meine Damen und Herren wir verurteilen
die jüngsten massiven Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung auf die zivile
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine die
Mobilisierung in Russland die Allianz
mit was Russland die völkerrechtswidrige
Annexion der besetzten Gebiete die
Angriffe auf so viele unschuldige
Menschen all das zeigt die wahnsinnige
Irrationalität dieses brutalen
Angriffskrieges und das zeigt auch dass
Putin immer mehr in Bedrängnis gerät
weil er führt den Krie jetzt so gegen
die Menschen die Zivilbevölkerung und es
trifft sie alle so grausam und hart es
ist brutal das bereitet mir und uns
große Sorgen gestern nun noch die
Verhängung des Kriegsrechts in den
sogenannten annektierten Gebieten hier
sollen neue Spannungen geschürt werden
ein vermeintlicher Angriff auch der
Ukraine auf vermeintlich russisches
Territorium dabei ist doch klar es gibt
kein russisches Kriegsrecht auf
ukrainischem Territorium meine Damen und
Herren
1100 ukrainische Orte Siedlung Dörfer
sind ohne Strom Angriffe auf Wohnhäuser
auf Krankenhäuser auf
Versorgungseinrichtungen auf Spielplätze
die
Zivilbevölkerung soll in Angst und
Schrecken versetzt werden die Menschen
leiden in dieser Situation unglaublich
und deshalb ist jede Kraftanstrengung
nötig und deshalb dürfen wir auch nicht
nachlassen in unserem Engagement
humanitär wirtschaftlich für den
Wiederaufbau für die Frage der
Beitrittsperspektive der EU und auch was
die Waffenlieferungen angeht meine Damen
und Herren jeden Tag müssen wir uns
fragen tun wir genug und was können wir
noch leisten dass es unsere Aufgabe im
europäischen Verbund
und meine Damen und Herren wer hier
einerseits die Solidarität mit der
Ukraine einfordert und mehr Solidarität
einfordert Herr Merz ich will Ihnen an
dieser Stelle sagen ich habe es an
anderer schon getan es hat wehgetan
wirklich weh getan und geschmerzt und
ihre halbseidene Entschuldigung hat
daran nichts geändert dass sie in dieser
schrecklichen Situation sich so
abwertend und populistisch gegenüber
geflüchteten Menschen in der Ukraine
geäußert haben
und es ist unverzeihlich
denn kurz nach ihrer Entschuldigung
wurde weiter nachgelegt in diesem Thema
und ich finde sie sollten das überdenken
denn wir haben hier alle eine große
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
noch in der Ukraine sind und dort in
ihrem Land bleiben und kämpfen und
gegenüber denen die hier sind und sich
nicht sehnlicher wünschen wieder
zurückzugehen in ihrer Heimat die so
bedroht ist und deshalb lassen Sie die
Finger davon mit dieser Methode
Populismus in dieser Art und Weise zu
arbeiten meine Damen und Herren und
wieder
und wieder haben wir gerade die
den Vorwurf gehört jetzt handelt mal
endlich
wo sind sie eigentlich in dieser
Situation wo sind sie in ihrer
Verantwortung in der größten Krise
dieses Landes und der größten Krise
Europas sich nicht in fundamental
Opposition zu verkriechen sondern
Verantwortung zu übernehmen meine Damen
und Herren
und jetzt mal kurz zum Thema diese
Regierung handelt nicht
meine Damen und Herren wir haben zwei
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
zur sozialen Abfederung die sind für
Menschen für Handwerk für Wirtschaft
eine Unterstützung und da können Sie 100
mal sagen es ist nicht der Fall es wirkt
wenn energiepreisbremse wenn
Unterstützungsleistungen für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner für Studierende
wenn die Frage der Grundsicherung erhöht
wird und und und und und und das sind
alles Maßnahmen die gezielt abfedern
sollen die sozialen Härten in diesem
Land und das ist gut und wichtig so der
200 Milliarden Abwehrschirm der gerade
geplant wird sie sollten nicht einfach
nur sagen das läuft nicht gut machen Sie
doch mal einen Vorschlag wo sind sie
denn da Griechen in ihren Löchern und
erklären jeden Tag wir würden nicht
handeln und weil sie da vielleicht eine
kleine Stütze brauchen sage ich Ihnen
mal kurz was diese Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit Robert Habeck ihm
Verantwortlichen Ministerium und den
anderen Ministerinnen auf den Weg
gebracht hat die Verpflichtung zu
befüllen der Gasspeicher die Forcierung
des Netzausbaus der Ausbau der Wind
Energie der schnellere Ausbau der
lng-terminals der wasserstoffausgleich
die Anpassung der Ausschreibungen für
Wind und Solar die
effizienz-standards das
Energieeffizienzgesetz die
Abstandsregeln aufheben die alle lange
die windenergieausbau Sachen blockiert
haben dass erneuerbare Energien Gesetz
das Energiewirtschaftsgesetz das
bundesbedarfsplanungsgesetz und
zahlreiche Verordnungen ich weiß es tut
ihnen weh wenn man das aufzählt weil
dann zeigt sich das konkret gehandelt
wird meine Damen und Herren und darum
geht es in dieser Krise genau darum geht
es in dieser Krise und ich erwarte von
ihnen dass sie Verantwortung übernehmen
und sie konstruktiv in diese
Lösungssuche einbringen meine Damen und
Herren wir sind in einer schweren Krise
und dass das notwendig und lassen Sie
mich zuletzt doch sagen als bitte und
zugleich als Aufforderung denn wir
wissen was die fossile Abhängigkeit
Russlands für unser Land in dieser Krise
bedeutet wir haben in den vergangenen
Monaten gesehen was das bedeutet und wir
sollten wenn wir über China diskutieren
dringend berücksichtigen was uns die
fossile Abhängigkeit und die zementierte
Abhängigkeit von Russland gekostet hat
keine Fehler in Bezug auf die
China-Politik meine Damen und Herren das
ist notwendig und das steht jetzt an
Britta Hasselmann hat vor allen Dingen
am Schluss gefordert dass die Opposition
Verantwortung übernehmen soll hat dann
eine Leistungsbilanz vorgelegt für was
der Wirtschaftsminister der grüne
Verantwortung tragen hat wie viel
Gesetze schon auf den Weg gebracht
worden sind und am Anfang hat sie gesagt
von diesem Gipfel um den es er geht
heute morgen Brüssel muss den Signal der
Geschlossenheit ausgehen tut es aber
leider nicht denn deutsch-französische
Achse knirscht Gewalt